souvent entendu parler de
le fait que la Russie ne peut pas vraiment
décision globale intéressée
problèmes environnementaux mondiaux, mais
Je peux immédiatement dire que c'est un non-sens, c'est un mythe, sinon
et franchement et jonglant comme et
d'autres parties nous ressentons des risques et des menaces
dans cette zone y compris la désertification
érosion du sol dégel du pergélisol
nous soutenons constamment
mise en œuvre de la Convention-cadre des Nations Unies sur
changement climatique
Protocole de Kyoto et Paris
les accords
il n'y a pas d'européen russe séparé
Climat asiatique ou américain
de tous nos pays une responsabilité commune
pour le monde moderne pour la vie de demain
générations alors que nous voyons la contribution de nos
pays à résoudre le problème du changement
le climat est confiant dans la force de l'échelle du lieu et
le rôle de la Russie et du monde
projets environnementaux et climatiques en
notre pays pendant de nombreuses décennies sera
jouer un rôle de premier plan dans les efforts mondiaux
préservation du climat